[Music]
our chris evans and jenny sleep back
together recent signs point to yes on
tuesday chris tweeted this hilarious
video of his dog Dodger and check this
out that mysterious female voice sounds
a lot like Jenny's then on Friday Jenny
confirmed that she has a beau tweeting
my boyfriend does many dreamy and
generous things the gifted co-stars also
had a flirty Twitter exchange in October
Chris kicked things off tweeting the
theme song to mash stresses me out the
Pavlovian response is that it's time to
go to bed and I probably haven't done my
homework
- which Jenny jokingly responded quote
probably haven't come on Christopher
have you done your homework or haven't
you it's 7 p.m. and you've had the whole
weekend come on Chris went on to propose
that they cut class and Jenny happily
accepted telling the superhero to meet
her behind the gym after science the
adorable duo broke up in early 2017
after 9 months of dating but they never
stopped gushing about one another
here's what they told ET when they
reunited for the gifted premiere in
April and seeing Chris again here
tonight how will that be free rise there
is Sun she's the best et has reached out
to both stars reps for comment
[Music]
you